Well,
I'd like to begin by pointing out that
the first name of Frederic Jameson is
spelled f. R. E. D. R. I. C. Uh,
there isn't, I point that out is that, uh,
most scholars don't seem to be
able to grasp that simple fact, uh,
and that references to him,
which are rife in the critical literature.
Uh, perhaps one third of the
time spell his first name wrong.
So I thought it would be important for
you to be among the cornea shanti. Uh,
and to know that it is spelled
in the way that I just mentioned.
It's a strange thing. Um, when I
started teaching, I taught many, many,
many sections of English one 29,
uh,
and of course in the second semester,
the first text that we read was the Iliad.
Now ill, it is spelled I l. I a. D.
Why it is that of the student population
I taught over all those years,
hundreds and hundreds of students,
fully. A third of them spelled it I, l.
L. I. A. D I really couldn't say,
but there are words that simply seem
to be in susceptible of being spelled
correctly.
And one,
and one of those words is the first
name of Frederic Jameson. So, um,
stand advised. Uh, okay. Now, um,
last time I talked about four possible
options of an aesthetic nature,
uh, for a Marxist approach to
literature and passed them in review,
a imagined realism,
both realism according to the tastes and
theoretical preferences of angles and
Luke couch also tendentious realism,
uh,
as it pervaded, uh, the Soviet world,
especially after 1934 a then also part
of the participatory aesthetic of figures
like Vaulter Benyamin,
the high modernist aesthetic of the whole,
uh,
embraced particularly by
Adorno. Those are the two, uh,
aesthetic modes that we passed in
review last time. Uh, and finally,
the idea that realism
being somehow out worn,
uh,
having a developed hardening of the
arteries as a kind of a bourgeois
perspective on things,
uh,
needs somehow or another to be
replaced as theoretically, uh,
in the Marxists do things
by something else. Uh,
and perhaps the most eloquent proponent
of replacing it with something,
uh,
is Jameson,
who earlier in the introductory
chapter of the political unconscious,
uh, much of which you've
been assigned for today. Uh,
writes a section which he
calls magical narratives, uh,
and which, uh, uh, promotes, um,
very much in keeping with the thinking
of Northrop Frye about the role of
romance in society,
particularly the religious
role of romance in society, uh,
proposes that and
aesthetic of the romance,
which entails a folklore, the
folk tale, the fairy tale,
uh,
various forms of folk expression as
magical resolution of conflicts that can't
otherwise be resolved,
uh,
is the more appropriate
aesthetic to take up.
And the long passage that
I sent to you last night,
which I'd like quickly
to go over, um, is, uh,
meant to further the promotion of,
of this aesthetic and also,
uh,
to pose for us a critique of what the
consequences would be of lingering with a
realist aesthetic.
And so Jameson says,
second passage on your sheet,
let Scott Balzac and Dreiser serve as the,
and remember that Balzac is the favorite
author of angles and Scott is the
favorite author of at
least in 1927 of Lucaj, uh,
and drives her is a figure from
the so-called naturalist movement,
the American novelist, uh, who, uh,
is a very appropriate addition to the
list. And so it's in that context that,
uh, that Jameson is dropping
these particular names.
Let Scott Balzac and Dreiser serve as
the non chronological markers of the
emergence of realism in its modern form.
These first great realism's
are characterized by a
fundamental and exhilarating
heterogeneity in their raw materials and
by a corresponding versatility in their
narrative apparatus at such moments,
a generic confinement to the existence.
In other words,
the only thing you have to do if you're
a realist is talk about things the way
they really are. Uh, at such moments,
a generic confinement to the existent
has a paradoxically liberating effect on
the registers of the text and releases
a set of heterogeneous historical
perspectives. The past for
Scott, the future for Balzac.
And the process of commodification for
Dreiser normally felt to be inconsistent
with a focus on the historical present.
In other words,
Scott's treatment of history
is dialectical against
the foil of the present.
There is a envisioned, a kind
of romanticized feudal, um,
uh, evocation of a feudal
past. Uh, and so it is in turn.
I don't want to linger long over
this with the other writers, uh,
normally felt to be inconsistent with
a focus on historical presence. Indeed,
this multiple temporality tends to be
sealed off and really contained again in
high realism and naturalism. In other
words, it starts getting too easy.
And the formulas of representing and
evoking the real began to become,
as I said, sclerotic, very
begin. They begin to harden.
They'd begin to confine us in ways,
uh,
that had hitherto been liberating where
a perfected narrative apparatus in
particular, the threefold imperatives
of authorial depersonalization.
That is to say the voice in steel and
direct labor ally to write, uh, uh,
indirect discourse, uh,
authorial depersonalization,
unity of point of view and restriction
to scenic representation begin to confer
on the realistic option,
the appearance of an US fixating
self-imposed pennants. And other words.
This is all I can say,
and this is the only way I can say it.
There are no other possibilities,
uh,
of literary expression because
I now feel confined to this,
uh,
to this reification of the reel.
This insistence that, uh, the real, um,
the evocation of the reel is
my only literary option. Uh,
and so it's no longer liberating.
Uh,
it is in the context of this gradual
reification in late capitalism that the
romance once again comes to be felt as
the place of narrative heterogeneity and
freedom from the reality
principle. And that is, uh,
in a way of jab at Freud,
uh,
but at the same time and
acknowledgement that Freud, uh,
participates in a sort of growing
despair over the necessity of confining
oneself to the real, um, the,
and freedom from the reality
principle to which a now oppressive,
realistic representation is the hostage.
Okay.
So that's the aesthetic
of Frederic Jameson.
And before we begin and analysis,
that is to say,
before we begin to consider his three
horizons or concentric circles of
interpretation from other points of view,
I thought it would be interesting to find
this romance aesthetic in those three
levels. We're talking of
course about the political,
the social, the historical,
the political, uh,
the kind of chronicle,
like as he puts it,
a record of successive,
uh, happen happenings,
ineffective context as a constructed
it as a plot by some individual voice,
the social as the conflict
or emergence into,
uh,
our awareness of its being a conflict
of what Jameson calls ideology teams.
That is to say ways of thinking about
the world as expressed by disparate and
conflicting classes.
And then finally the historical,
which Jameson calls necessity. At the
end of the essay he says it's what hurts.
Ah,
but which in terms of literary
analysis as we'll see has to do with
understanding the overlap of the
succession of modes of production as they
unfold in historical time.
And we'll have more to say
about modes of production,
but our basic three horizons then,
uh,
which are in which I'm now going
to look for the romance aesthetic.
Our basic three horizons then are
what Jameson calls the political,
the social and the historical.
It's,
it's important that he does sometimes
call them concentric circles because you
have to understand that as you
advance through the three stages,
you're not leaving anything behind.
The historical is contained within
the social and the social is contained
within,
I'm sorry,
the political is contained within the
social and the social is contained within
the historical and all of that is what
we is not to be left behind but is rather
to be rethought.
Reconsidered Jameson sometimes
use the word rewritten,
a thinking of the text that want,
that is the object of one study. Uh,
as one advances through these
three stages. So that's why,
that's why he thinks it appropriate
to call them concentric circles. Well,
in any case,
so what is the political,
the essential political,
uh,
moment of the creative act?
Well,
it's what Jameson borrowing from
Kenneth Burke calls the symbolic act.
As an individual writer,
I undertake to resolve
symbolically a contradiction.
And Marxism is always about contradiction.
That is to say the way in which the way
in which the perspective of any class,
uh,
exists in country in a
contradictory relation,
both with its own needs and
desires and with other classes.
In any case,
then the symbolic act at the political
level is designed to resolve a
contradiction that can't
be resolved by other means.
In other words, it's a
fantasy. It is the fairy tale.
It is the princess and the pauper.
It is the arbitrary happy ending tacked
onto a situation for which in reality
there would be no happy ending.
In other words,
it is a romance perspective about a world,
the re the realistic
approach to which, um, uh,
would somehow or another leave
us feeling much more confined.
Slumdog millionaire, uh,
is an interesting example.
Uh, it's an old tourists
film made by Danny Boyle. Uh,
an interesting example of an individual
act which magically resolves a
contradiction through the whole Bollywood
apparatus that it brings to bear on
it. And the contradictions of course,
are rife between his Hindu and Muslim.
The contradictions entailed and
globalization, the contradictions of cast.
All of these contradictions not to
be resolved on a realistic plane,
nevertheless, can be resolved
by an individual symbolic act.
You hit the lotto, you know, you win, uh,
against all odds.
A prize that makes you a millionaire
who wants to be a millionaire?
Have we all want to be millionaires,
but only one of us,
the miraculously, magically, uh,
through a series of completely implausible
happen happenstances is able to do
so.
Now notice this.
It's not that it doesn't happen.
People do hit the lotto.
People do when the $64 thousand
thousand dollar question of whatever.
It's not that, it's not that
it's absolute never, never land.
But the point is,
and,
and I think this is really ultimately
the point of that extravagant dance and
the railroad station. At the
end of the film, the point,
the point is that even
were to happen in reality,
it wouldn't resolve contradictions.
That is to say your life would not
have the kind of scripted perfection.
You get the girl,
everything is going to be perfect.
The whole world falls in line
dancing behind you. You know,
this just this, this just
doesn't happen. In other words,
it's sort of tragic to hit the lotto.
As many stories of that kind have made
clear to us and that it seems to me is
finally how the film is somewhat self
conscious about its nature as a symbolic
act in any way.
That's the romance element of the
political level of interpretation as
understood by Jameson.
Now the second level
brings to the surface the element of
subversion that has to be entailed in this
same fairy tale resolution of a conflict
that can't otherwise be resolved.
There are all sorts of other
aspects at the second level,
but remember I'm discovering the romance
aesthetic here in all three levels
before turning to other matters
having to do them. So let's say,
I mean at the second
level, on page 12, 97, uh,
the right hand column,
um, you have, um, uh,
aunts blocks understanding
of the fairytale.
This is at the second level by about
two thirds of the way down. Thus,
for instance,
blocks reading of the fairytale with
its magical wish fulfillments and it's
utopian fantasies of plenty and the pay
to you restores the dialogical and the
Big Rock Candy Mountain,
basically as the paid Corecon restores
the dialogical and antagonistic content
of this form by exhibiting it
as a systematic deconstruction
and undermining of
the hedge demonic aristocratic
form of the epic. In other words,
it's not just a symbolic act,
the fairy tale.
It is a thumbing of the
nose at hedge emoney.
It is in other words
and act of antagonism,
which of course recognizes
the impossibility of
resolution or reconciliation
precisely in its register of antagonism.
So that at the second level,
the social level in which the
ideological voices of various glasses and
perspective are openly in conflict.
You don't get resolution once you
get is subversion and reaction.
You get,
in other words,
a tension of voices that is not meant to
resolve anything but as rather meant to
lay bare the conflicts that are entailed.
And still, however, in doing this,
you get the kind of the,
the, the kind of of, uh,
carnivalesque uprising from below,
which a Jameson associates with
romance that letting off of steam,
that, uh, uh,
entertaining the possibility
of utopia that you get,
for example, in the early modern
period on that day, which is called,
uh,
in which someone is called
the Lord of Misrule.
And the entire social order
for one day is inverted, uh,
and the low are elevated to
a positions of authority.
Uh, and for one day, uh, you get
the keys to the castle and effect.
This is a day in which
conflict is expressed and not
resolved because everybody
knows that tomorrow it's going
to be the same old, same old, uh,
and back to business as usual.
And so, but the romance element,
the idea that the idea that the,
that folk expression is simultaneously
the expression of a wish,
a wish, similar to the wish that's
expressed at the first political level,
but, but, but, but the expression
of a wish, which is collective,
that is to say in behalf of a class and
a perspective and which is also with
great consciousness,
not aware that can in any
way expect to be fulfilled,
but rather one that has used subversively
with respect to the dominant ideology.
Uh, that it, it, it, it, it,
it expresses its abrasiveness.
A tort third level
involves the way in which,
uh, there is at any given
time, the historical level,
a dominant mode of production.
Emotive production is a system is
a system of thought or production,
uh,
generated by a,
an overarching social or
economic arrangement. Uh,
Jameson lists them in his text.
Uh, and we'll come back to them.
Uh, and we'll read that listing
and we'll think about those terms.
The Jameson gives an excellent example
of the way in which in the latter part of
the 18th century,
the enlightenment began to be
the dominant form of expression.
All of an emergent Merkin toll
successfully capitalist bourgeoisie.
That is to say the values
that drove, uh, uh,
the development of industrialization and
capital were those values emerging from
feudal, uh, and aristocratic ideals,
less realistic,
less engaged with actuality,
and the way in which you can actually
get things done in the world. Uh,
the enlightenment is understood as an
expression of an emerging new mode of
production. Capitalism,
Asic succeeds feudalism,
but Jameson points out and
here's where romance comes in.
And then after that we'll
move on to our next point.
But Jameson points out at the same time
you get enlightenment at the same time
that that does seem to become
the dominant form of expression.
You also get two modes of
resistance or contest station.
On the one hand,
you have romanticism,
which can be understood in this context
as a kind of atavistic throwback to
aristocratic and futile idealism,
codes of conduct,
beliefs, uh, uh, visions of Utopia, uh,
within romanticism.
All of them sort of trying to re code,
uh, in an age of enlightenment, um,
various sorts of idealism that
had come to seem outmoded.
So that's a kind of of, uh, as it were,
reactionary mode of production overlapping
with or expressing itself through,
uh,
the dominant one.
And then at the same time you get folk
resistance to the mechanization of the
enlightenment with political economy
and with the rise of social engineering,
uh, and with the various forms of, of,
of social organization associated
with utilitarian. With utilitarianism,
you get, uh, you get folk resistance,
you get popular resistance in the
forms of protest frame breaking,
a disruption of labor activity,
uh,
protest against industrialization,
all of which also because it insists
on earlier forms of agricultural and
industrial sort of cottage industry.
And it's on all of
which is also atavistic.
Also a throwback to the way in which
labor is performed or conducted,
a under feudalism. And so that to, uh,
in the form of folk
expression of longing for,
in this case a utopian past,
more agrarian,
more individualized,
as, as a mode of labor,
more cottage or added in all
of this, you get, um, uh,
an overlapping mode of production.
So the tension among modes of production,
which is the focus of analysis
at the historical level,
the third historical level can also be
understood in terms of the romance of
Utopian Nostalgia.
All right,
so that then just to show
how Jameson's aesthetic,
his sense of the importance of romance
can be seen to pervade the way in which
he understands analysis at
all three of these levels.
So that's his aesthetic question then,
is what is the interpretive payoff of
undertaking literary analysis at these
three levels? That is
to say, why should we,
why should we take the trouble to do it?
What's so interesting about it? Well,
from Jameson's point of view,
this of course is the title of his book.
Each of these three modes of analysis,
uh,
is designed to disclose,
to uncover,
to lay bare and element of
the political unconscious.
As for deconstruction.
As for Freud,
this sense of a political
unconscious exposes,
reveals something that is antithetical
to ordinary consciousness.
That is to say, uh, undermines the,
our conventional understanding of things
shows us that beneath our conventional
understanding of things,
there are laws and causes
and dynamics at work, uh,
that we need to understand.
Uh, in this case, however,
the unconscious and question is
not a linguistic unconscious.
It is not a psychological unconscious.
It is a political unconscious in so far.
In other words,
as we are political animals,
the acts that we perform,
the dialogues that we engage in,
the modes of production
that we participate in,
all of them have political ramifications.
That is to say,
we w we,
we do what we do as opposed to doing other
things for political reasons of which
we may not be fully aware.
Hence the emphasis in analysis of this
kind on the political unconscious.
So again,
the three levels,
going back to the idea
of the symbolic act,
what political unconscious in other words,
is revealed by a, by a symbolic act? Well,
Jameson gives a wonderful example
taken from structuralism and he,
and you can see that he leans very
heavily on structuralism for his
understanding,
uh,
of the way in which of the way in which
something is going on in a narrative
form of which it is not immediately
apparent that anybody can be aware.
Take for example,
[inaudible] face painting.
Why Levy Strauss asks both
in the savage mind and again,
in Trieste stroke peak,
why the excessive complexity
of these paintings,
why the curious tension in the marks on
the faces between the vertical and the
horizontal? Why is, you
know, why, in other words,
do you get a kind of, have a feeling
of tension, aesthetic beauty,
but also of, of, of,
of tension and complication
in this cross hatching,
in the sense of the relation between the
vertical and the horizontal Jameson's
argument, which he brings out
more clearly than Levy Strauss.
But Levy Strauss says the same thing.
A contrasting the Caddo video in this
respect that with neighboring tribes like
the Bharara,
the explanation is that the
category are a hierarchical society,
uh,
in which there are open and obvious forms
of inequality that one must perforce
be aware of as a member of the tribe,
but that neighboring tribes,
and this is something that probably
the tribe itself can observe,
work out a way of seeming to resolve
the contradictions and to inherent in
hierarchy by the exchange of loyalty,
moieties of or which is to say, of, of,
of kinship gifts and wedding
gifts and so on. Uh, that, uh,
that Levy Strauss talks about and this
exchange of mortise seems to impose on
these social orders in real life,
in real terms,
a way of making society more
equal than it might otherwise be.
Yes, it's still hierarchical, but at
the same time, wealth is distributed.
Each person has his own form of
asserting dignity and Zoe on the cat Aveo
doesn't have this Levy
Strauss's and Jameson's boy
is that the [inaudible] never
really worked that out so that they're
stuck with a simple form of hierarchical
organization face painting.
Then according to Levy Strauss followed
by Janssen is their way of symbolically
resolving the problem by
introducing the horizontal,
by introducing,
in other words,
the ways in which other tribes have
successfully offset hierarchy by ways of
distributing wealth more equally deep
wealth and prestige more equally and that
the symbolic act which other tribes were
able to accomplish in real life in real
terms,
the Caddo Aveo Express,
I accomplish individually each individual
woman painting her face as a symbolic
act,
a symbolic act expressing the political
unconscious because this is not an act
we suppose of which any
individual is aware.
I mean you can the unawareness,
the lack of consciousness of what's
going on and a story is much more readily
available to us in the
Oedipus myth because that's
the part of Levy Strauss is a
structural study of myth.
We happy it happened to have read.
The next part is category or basement,
but the structure and the Structural
Study of Myth Levy Strauss begins by
talking about the Oedipus might as well.
The whole point of that is cheap.
There's a terrible contradiction born
from two or born from one plainly,
no individual version of the story,
certainly not Sophocles
version is sang to itself. Oh,
this is a terrible contradiction.
I don't know whether I'm born for two
people or born from one person. That's,
that is the unconscious. In other words
of the story which is brought out,
brought to the surface by a
structuralist analysis of the meth.
Jameson doesn't talk about it because
it's not in any obvious and immediate way
a political problem or a problem
susceptible of Marxist analysis.
It is perhaps ultimately everything
is, but, uh, not immediately.
And so he turns instead to a discussion
of the cat countervail myth, um,
which has as it's unconscious and issue,
that's obviously a political one,
but it is nevertheless the case that a
structural analysis of a symbolic act is
designed to and will inevitably reveal
an element of unconscious thought,
political or otherwise.
And that then is the way in which the
political unconscious as Jameson describes
it, is brought out at the first
political level of understanding, uh,
the individual symbolic act,
not the second level,
the social in which the
text as Jameson says,
rewrites itself,
not as an individual act,
but as very much in the
spirit of buck teen, um,
a Hetero Glossop expression of voices of
points of view writing themselves as it
were through the text there,
the political unconscious in
question, um, is something that,
uh, it has to be understood in terms
of ideology means in other words,
people reflexively xpress perhaps
unbeknownst to themselves,
views and opinions which are intelligible,
not arising out of their individuality,
not because they are who they
are as they themselves might say,
but rather because of their
economic class and prestige status.
In other words,
because of their place in the world,
it follows that they
will hold certain views,
they will be the mouthpieces, in
other words, for certain ideology,
genes and those ideologies.
Uh, Jameson understands, uh,
to be at least in part
unconscious one doesn't know.
And other words that the opinions
one so fervently expresses.
And so devoutly believes in our opinions
conditioned by the social circumstances
in which one finds oneself.
So that literature then becomes
a kind of drama of ideology,
means a representation of
unresolved conflict, uh,
sort of manifest in the variety of class,
uh, or status voices, uh, brought to bear.
And you can see this is
the point at which, uh,
Jameson's work is closest to Bach teens
and most and most clearly reflects some
of the preoccupations of Bactine as,
as we've encountered them already.
Jameson gives a very good example of
the way in which this conflict works
because it's a at par part of the
mystery of these clashes as that they are
always present as is,
that they always present themselves
with a sh within a shared code.
This already begins to look forward to
the idea of the mode of production. Uh,
at the bottom of page 12, 96, Jameson
who was talking about the grit,
the violent religious controversies
of the 17th century in England,
uh, between cavalier and
roundhead, between, uh,
all the controversies
surrounding, uh, the, uh,
interregnum of Commonweal, uh, the
restoration of Charles the second, uh,
and the tremendous ferment religion,
largely religious ferment, uh,
taking place during those
periods during that period.
But this ferment for any Marxist and
Christopher Hill is the leading historian
writing about this period who has made,
made it most clearly a
intelligible in these terms. Uh,
for any Marxist.
These,
this conflict has an underlying political
unconscious that is its ultimate
motives are and assertion
of rights, uh, and, uh,
an expression of class views.
This is the way James and
puts it bottom of page 1296.
The normal form of the dialogical
is essentially an antagonistic one.
He's referees at alluding here to Bactine
for whom frequently the dialogical is
simply a kind of a happy
cacophony of voices,
a carnivalesque, uh,
expression of chaos from below,
all of which is a kind of yeast like
ferment. Um, and somehow or another,
and the long run, uh, energizing, uh,
and socially progressive,
uh,
but Jameson points up that dial
that the dialogue them is, is,
is very often a expressive of
conflict as well and antagonistic one.
And that the dialogue of class struggle
is one in which two opposing discourses
fight it out within the
general unity of a shared code.
Thus,
for instance,
the shared master code
of religion becomes,
and the 1640s in England,
the place in which the
dominant formulations of a
hedge demonic theology are
reappropriated and polemically modified.
In other words,
the Church of England stands for as,
and this is the word that
was used as stablish meant
roundhead points of view.
Various forms of puritanism and other
forms of religious rebellion are anti
establishment.
And yet they are all coded within the
sort of discourse of the Christian
religion.
That is to say they have to fight
it out on a common battlefield.
And that's the way it is
with conflict of this kind.
Maybe a contemporary example,
uh,
would be not so much in the
sphere of religion as well today.
One could could speak
again, uh, of religion. But,
uh, in the sixties and seventies, it
was maybe more a question of ethics.
Think for example of the sexual
revolution, the ECOM, you know, again,
there's a common ground,
you know,
a sense of the central reality
of sexual conduct to human life.
But there are, but, but what
you get in the, not so much,
perhaps conflict of classes is
conflict of generations. In this case,
what you get in conflict of
generations is an inversion of values.
Not a new set of values.
Exactly.
But a simple trans
valuation of what exists.
Everything that one faction
considers bad, uh, another faction,
trans values, and considered as good.
The various, the, the, the, the,
the very thing against which one is worn
is the thing that one rushes to embrace
and so on. So once again, you
get a clash and unresolved clash,
but a class that arises
from and participates in
the semiotic structure of a
common code,
right?
And that's the way in which social
antagonism expresses itself,
uh, at the second level. Uh,
and it usually involves because there
isn't, there are underlying interests,
uh, elements of the political unconscious
brings to the surface elements of the
political unconscious.
Finally, at the third level,
what comes out,
what is made manifest is the tension or
clash among modes of production as they
jostle each other.
Historically,
it's understood that the danger as
Jameson puts it of thinking in terms of a
succession of modes of production is that
each one of those modes of production
might see like a synchronic moment. In
other words, if you're in capitalism,
you might get lulled into thinking that
no other motive production is available.
If you're in patriarchy,
you might get lulled into thinking that
no other mode of production is available.
And yet as Jameson points
out, the tension between, uh,
between corporate hierarchy
and patriarchal hierarchy,
the tension, in other words, which,
uh, very often drives a wedge,
has driven a wedge in polemic between
Marxist and feminist points of view,
uh,
is a reflection of the coexistence of
modes of production from completely
different areas. One contemporary
one completely, uh, uh,
it's at least insofar as it was the
dominant a thing of the past and yet
presenting, uh, and still, uh,
overlapping with a mode of
production that is contemporary.
So all of that, uh, is, is sort of, is,
is simply a matter of historical fact.
But in literary analysis and
literary analysis, um, you begin,
you begin to think of it in more
formal terms and you see, uh,
for example,
uh,
the very choice of verse form,
and I'm,
I'm taking as an example,
uh, uh, Shelly's famous poem,
the Ode to the West Wind.
You see the very choice of verse form
as an instance of what Jameson calls the
ideology of form and can under can be
understood in terms of the conflict of
mode of production.
The verse form of Shelley's Ode to
the West Wind is simultaneously,
it has five stroll fees and each stroke
fee is exactly the same informed it is
simultaneously a sonnet.
And the first 12 lines of which
concluding in a couple of, uh,
a succession of Teradata [inaudible].
Now these two forms brought together
synthesize as a single stroller fiqh forum
in Shelly are coated and
entirely different ways.
Each aspect of them has an ideology.
Terrizi rema is coated prophecy because
it is in the tradition of Dante.
It's the verse form in which the divine
comedy is written and it is add a mode
that is expressive of hope that
resolves all contradiction,
uh, in the divine, in the
revelation of the divine,
in the parodies up so that the tariffs,
the Rhema expresses for
Shelly the hope of the poem,
which is that the west
wind will be through him.
The prompt,
the trumpet of a political prophecy.
If winter's here can spring be far behind,
uh,
revolution is in the offing.
Everything's going to be great,
but at the same time,
the palm is shot through with
a kind of pessimism, a sort of,
if you will,
realism and awareness that this notion
of prophecy is rather farfetched.
Why should the wind do his bidding?
The wind is just when
it's not inspiration. Uh,
therefore the, the various stands
up, which is written in Tasa.
Rema is written at the same
time as a sonnet 14 lines.
And the first stanza in particular
is coated not just as a Sonnet,
but also as an illusion,
specifically to one sonnet and
particular Shakespeare's 73rd,
which begins that time of year
in me, thou mayest be hold, uh,
uh, in which I'm getting old. My bare
root might my, I don't have any hair left.
I'd mind sort of, I, I'm just a bare
ruined choir where late sweet bird sang.
In other words,
I'm in a parlous state.
I'm getting old and there's
nothing to be done about it. Uh,
at the end of the poem,
uh,
the embers of my fire are about to be,
are about to be snuffed out.
There is just no hope for it. Uh,
that's the way it is. You
get old. In other words,
winters here and spring in coming,
there is no prophetic possibility.
There is only the reality of
the trajectory of a lifespan.
If there's rise, there's also
fall. If there's development,
there's also decline and decay.
And these, uh, as the, as,
as the sonnet form codes,
it are simple facts of life,
that poetic idealism that
Romanticism cannot override.
So what you get in Shell is verse
form is a tension between ideas,
the eye, the eye, the prophetic
idea, which you can associate with a,
with a feudal and Theo
centric world in wets.
The contradictions of reality really
can be resolved theologically on the one
hand and a kind of protocol,
realist tradition and which we just have
to come to terms with the way things
are coded through,
which is after all a Prodo enlightenment.
I mean,
and Shaw and Shakespeare is often
sort of thought thought of as a pro
enlightenment figure. Uh, and
that is coded through the Sonnet.
So formally
both the tarts,
the rema and the sonnet participate in
what Jameson calls the ideology of form.
And they raise,
they reflect modes of production,
feudal and enlightenment respectively.
And they respect and they
reflect attitudes that one
can associate with those
modes of production. So that's an
example of the way in which the Po,
the sort of the political perhaps
wanted better call it cuase.
I conscious because Shelly was
an incredibly self conscious,
but the way in which the political
quasar conscious expresses itself at the
third or historical level of analysis.
Um, now, um, so in formal
terms, and I've already, and,
and I've already sort of gotten into this
and I'll go through it rather quickly
because there isn't much time
left. Um, informal terms.
We can think of the, uh,
the essential critical,
uh,
task at the first or historical
level as one of theme at Ization.
That is to say what theme is the plot
structure of an individual symbolic act
trying to express what are we,
you know,
what is the contradiction that's
being resolved in this symbolic act?
At the second level,
the formal principal that we,
that we do bring to bear is the idea,
the Bach Tinian idea of Heteroglossia,
the clash of voices,
the way in which the voice
is no longer individual,
but rather social, uh, the
representative a social point of view.
And it expresses itself
through, um, uh, the, the, the,
the individual authors writing.
And at the third level,
you get what Jason calls a repertoire
of devices. And I've already, uh,
reflected a little bit on that.
Let me just add another example also taken
from Romanticism and keeping with, uh,
Jameson's is exemplification of the
overlap of modes of production as being
particularly interesting in the age
of enlightenment. In Romanticism,
there's a long,
there's a long tradition leading up to it,
of the formal pindaric Ode.
Uh,
Wordsworth is still making use of that
tradition in writing his own intimations
of immortality.
But in the meantime,
he and Coleridge have
developed a new kind of owed,
if you will,
which is called the conversation
Palm Coleridge's frosted midnight.
This lime tree Bauer,
my prison Wordsworth's Tintern Abbey,
notable examples of the conversation poem.
Now the difference is very
clearly intelligible in
terms of a conflict of modes
of production.
The formal owed a derived
ultimately from Pindar celebrating,
uh,
Olympic victories of
aristocratic patrons in Greece,
a horse races, foot races,
wrestling matches. Uh, that's,
that's the original purpose to
which the formal owed was put, uh,
plainly,
uh,
is coded once again a feudal aristocratic,
whereas the conversation poem
belongs very much as the title,
as the word suggests in the public sphere.
It's the atmosphere of the coffee house.
It's the atmosphere in which
people sit down and talk together,
exchange views,
address each other.
It is a poem always have address to some
individual person that turns to that
person at a certain point. Um, uh,
evokes the nature of that person
sometimes solicits that person's opinions.
In other words,
it's upon that performs Diallo Ism.
It's upon that performs, uh, the sense of,
of the given take of a much more open
democratic culture in the public sphere.
And so you can see that they're very
transitioned from the formal owed to the
conversation.
Palm is itself intelligible
as a transition among,
uh,
or what Jameson calls a
cultural revolution brought
about by a seismic shift in
modes of production. All right, so
these exemplify in various ways,
in various ways what can be done with
these three levels. Jameson himself, uh,
reminds us of the dangers.
If we think of a narrative
as a symbolic act,
we're a much too prone either to
forget that it's based in reality by
emphasizing the structuralist nature of
what's going on or to forget that that
form is involved at all,
uh,
by emphasizing the social
contradiction that's being resolved.
And as Jameson says,
these two dangerous at the first level
or the danger of structuralism and the
danger of vulgar materialism.
The point in analyzing the symbolic act
is to sustain a balance or a synthesis
between formal, uh, and uh, social, uh,
elements within the text. Um,
the, at the, at the second level,
the problem is that if we start thinking
in terms of unreconcilable class
conflict,
our analysis can become static as though
class perspectives didn't shift as
though,
uh,
one perspective might succeed
another as the hedge demonic.
In other words,
as though change didn't take place as
though there was always the same old,
same old in class conflict,
the boss is always going to
speak demeaningly or the worker,
the worker is always going to laugh
at the boss behind his back. Uh,
this is the way it is.
This is the way it will always be.
There are static relations.
In other words, uh,
among the classes that history
can't resolve. And finally, uh,
at the third level, there's the danger
of thinking in terms of impasse, uh,
late capitalism for example,
as an impasse that simply
can't be surmounted.
Think of Adorno they give a darn off and
his incredible gloom about the culture
industry, there isn't much hope in a
door. No. Is there, and by the same token,
you could argue that poor old Jameson,
you know,
talking about history as necessity,
history is what hurts, you know,
history is just what has happened.
You know, by the same token,
you could argue that Jameson to is perhaps
a little bit subject to this sense of
impasse,
which is why I quote for you as
these people themselves often do,
you know,
the ringing a warning of mark of marks
in the 11th thesis on Foreign Bach,
the philosophers have only interpreted
the world in various ways. The point,
however, is to change it. That is
ultimately the focus of Marxist analysis.
Tony in the remaining minute.
Now a reified realist approach to Tony.
The kind that Jameson criticizes in
his sheet would point out that nothing
happens to Nido and speedy.
They are manifest villains and had at
the same time nothing can happen to them.
They are simply, they simply have
their place in the social order.
One of them is a fastidious aristocrat
who doesn't want to get dirty.
The other is,
you know,
completely committed to productivity
and the time clock and the work ethic,
but a speedy, ah, there they
are. Nothing to be done.
They're not nice to Tony,
but nothing happens to them.
There is no recrimination
but that at the first level,
if we understand this as a symbolic act,
the resolution of what would otherwise
be a hopeless conflict is through
friendship.
The friendship of bumpy and Tony.
They have to the fact that it's
perfectly okay if I'm just a working guy.
I've got my buddies, we go out, we drink
beer, we have a good time. Life is great.
You know, that is, you
know, it doesn't matter.
In other words that there's a class
structure that there's a social system.
You know, I'm happy.
Tony says, I like my job.
That in itself of course is a resolution
is a symbolic act and a resolution in
advance of the conflicts that the
story might otherwise manifest.
The second level you get the discourse
of ideology. Jeans, I can't help you.
He says, Nieto of the car.
I don't want to get dirty.
I can't help you said speed you the car.
I am too busy.
I can help you says bumpy,
but notice that this is all within an
individual single code in that that that's
what the,
the the complete parallel parallelism of
these three utterances shows us within
a single code these ideology which
can't really been re be resolved,
get themselves expressed. All right.
Now finally, modes of production.
Plainly,
the very existence of a Nido and speedy
in the same story suggest that there is
a certain tension between the
feudal and the bourgeois at work,
but it's not attention that in any
way necessarily works itself out.
The important thing to notice here,
it seems to me is the conflict
between pulling and pushing.
I mean it's very interesting. I've
said this before, that a tow truck,
something that polls and,
and, and you know, once again,
you know this Tony is a mode
of production, right? I mean
he's a tow truck, right?
That something,
something that pulls,
has to be pushed bumpy,
you know,
is like the little engine that could,
is a sort of a throwback to an earlier,
uh,
less energized,
less powerful mode of production.
He has to push, think of the
way walls get put up, you know,
a prefabricated wall before the invention
of the crane and the pulley has to be
pushed up by a bunch of people.
Pushing is the essential labor mode
before the kind of technology arises that
makes it possible to pull something.
After that you have a crane,
you run the hook down,
you just pull the wall up into place
before then you've got maybe one person
standing on a rafter with
a rope kind of pulling.
But everybody else is down
on the ground pushing.
And so the relationship between pushing
and pulling in the story is a crucially
important one,
which suggests the overlap of older
and newer modes of production,
uh,
all of which can be resolved at Jameson's
third or historical level of analysis.
Okay.
So much then for Jameson and for Tony
will be coming back to Tony again next
time. In the context of talking
about the new historicism.